bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le site du
figaro c'est figaro live ses points de
vue en visio encore une fois ce soir
avec jérôme sainte-marie politologue
président de l'institut polling bugs et
auteur d'un livre absolument à lire bloc
contre bloc la dynamique du maquereau
nisme c'est aux éditions du cerf bonsoir
jérôme bonsoir vincent bonsoir à tous
mathilde de broc et également avec nous
porte parole du think tank libéral
génération libre fondée notamment par le
philosophe libéral gaspard koenig
bonsoir mathilde et nous avons également
là avec nous le maître bertrand perrier
bonsoir avocat on sent là bonsoir mon
cher bertrand auteur de deux livres à
emporter pendant vos prochaines vacances
à lire en tout cas avant la rentrée sur
le bout de la langue vous le voyez le
plaisir du mot juste sorte de
dictionnaire amoureux de la justice et
de la profession d'avocat on pourrait
dire ça et puis un manuel absolument
avoir lu si on veut apprendre et surtout
si on craint de parler en public
la parole est un sport de combat les
deux livres sont aux éditions jean
claude lattès avec nous aussi ce soir on
s'en réjouit richard wehrli
correspondant à paris de l'excellent
quotidien suisse le temps justement
richard alors juste vous allez activer
votre micro parce que je n'ai pas
entendu mais je sais que vous nous avez
dit bonsoir richard mais aussi mathilde
bertrand jérôme et vous qui nous regarde
et je vous propose de revenir sur deux
thèmes d'abord une mesure qui a été
largement commentée depuis 48 heures et
qui figure dans les propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat la
réduction à 110 km/heure sur les
autoroutes et pendant que je vous parle
vous entendez que richard wehrli est
bien avec nous et puis il commentera
avec vous avec elle les autres
intervenants cette proposition du géant
d'amazon d'ouvrir une demi-douzaine
d'entrepôts en france alors faut-il
fermer les yeux faut-il ouvrir les bras
fermer les yeux sur les impôts que ne
paye pas la firme américaine ou bien
ouvrir
les bras à une entreprise qui me promet
400 500 voix peut-être plus d'emplois en
france richard mathilde mathieu richard
amatil pardon bertrand jérôme et vous
qui nous regardent et j'attends vos
réponses j'attends vos questions
également
j'attends vos commentaires j'attends vos
avis vos avis et j'attends vos amis
également pour ne regarder et pour nous
donner ce soir vos points de vue
[Musique]
alors faut-il limiter la vitesse à 110
km heure sur l'autoroute vous avez été
plus de 100 milles à répondre à la
question posée sur le site du figaro
plus de 83% à répondre non on vous
propose ce soir la question sur twitter
est aujourd'hui dans les commentaires
vous êtes extrêmement nombreux à
fustiger cette proposition issue de la
convention citoyenne sur le climat à
l'image donc de mx qui dénonce je cite
une mesure démagogique tout comme les 80
kilomètres heure
eh bien m x voici ce qu'a répondu à
cette comparaison à l'ancienne tête de
liste verte européenne
yannick jadot pourquoi ça a été mal
ressenti ces 80 km heure parce que
c'était le mépris de paris pour les
zones rurales
là on parle des autoroutes dont rêvent
les autoroutes c'est pas les populations
les plus vulnérables qui utilisent les
autoroutes ils les utilisent aussi mais
c'est tout le monde voulait plus du tout
dans le mépris de paris pour les zones
rurales
et bien si cette mesure permet
effectivement de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique de manière
efficace ces quelques minutes de perdues
aux 100 km et si on compensait par
exemple mais ce se porte tout en
baissant les tarifs sur les autoroutes
alors c'est une proposition qu'on va
commenter mais avant richard wehrli
j'aurais aimé avoir votre point de vue
la question je vous pose c'est qu'en
pense le suisse que vous êtes à ma
connaissance et dans mon souvenir en
tous les cas l'autoroute zurich genève
le 110 km/heure est en vigueur sur les
autoroutes helvétiques
pour moi ces descentes août et moi
j'avoue que cette nouvelle limitation je
ne sais pas quand même si elle vient à
point nommé
un moment donné où il y a une forte
préoccupation effectivement écologique
en france mais il ya aussi besoin de
réconcilier les français entre eux pour
une ambition commune allait remettre la
question de la vitesse qui risque de
diviser
je ne sais pas si politiquement c'est
très souhaitable donc peut-être que sur
le plan écologique ça se défend
peut-être même qu'il faut afficher cette
ambition à moyen terme
mais allez tout de suite repartir avec
ce qui est quand même une interdiction
esquissera mal vécue par une partie de
la population ce qui peut occasionner de
nouvelles fractures
je m'interroge sur le calendrier pour
l'essentiel vous vous interrogez sur le
calendrier
mathilde bloqués est-ce que vous
interrogez sur le calendrier je
j'aimerais vous partager ce que nous dit
ce que le dc peuvent sur les dents les
commentaires du figaro qu'est ce qui
empêche les partisans de cette mesure de
rouler à 110 km heure dès maintenant
puisqu'il semble être si nombreux cela
aura un effet non négligeable pas besoin
d'une loi
est-ce que c'est l'avis de la libérale
que vous êtes la vie de la libérale que
je suis c'est qu'il faut toujours mieux
faire de la pédagogie que de
l'interdiction
donc j'aurais bien sûr tendance à dire
qu'il faut laisser les gens rouler à 110
km heure s'ils le souhaitent
maintenant ce que la vie que j'ai
surtout sur cette loi c'est que c'est
une mesurette que je vois comme
greenwashing et je trouve ça un peu
dommage
les enjeux climatiques c'est des enjeux
qui sont énormes et on a besoin de
mesures à la hauteur de l'ambition
climatique et je pense que mettre en
avant une mesure qui a à ce point clivé
quand on parlait des 80 km heure
rappelons nous que c'était l'un des
sujets de grogne qui a donné naissance
obligé au gd jaune forecast et l'inde et
des carburants qui a qui a alimenté la
crise des gilets jaunes on revient sur
ce sujet là à l'issue d'une convention
qui est née de la crise des gilet jaune
je trouve ça un petit peu ironique un
peu paradoxal et je pense surtout que
médecin 10 km en france c'est pas la
manière pertinente
il faut se poser la question au niveau
européen et c'est à ce niveau là
seulement on pourra prendre la mesure
des enjeux qu la problématique
climatique
jérôme sainte-marie je vois cligner des
yeux
qu'est ce que vous en pensez et question
subsidiaire
est-ce que vous balayer d'un revers de
main la proposition de janick yannick
jadot
certains internautes nous disant ce
moment ce n'est que du pur affichage
électoral à quelques jours du deuxième
tour des élections municipales
j'avoue ne pas bien comprendre le
raisonnement de yannick jadot
tout d'abord parce que la question n'est
pas le mépris de paris pour les zones
rurales c'est pas la question d'ailleurs
pour les 80 kilomètres à leur niveau on
se bat pas pour du mépris ou du respect
contrairement à ce qu'on nous fait dire
ce qu'on nous dit actuellement ils se
battent pour leurs conditions concrètes
d'existence c'est ils se battent pour
pouvoir travailler essentiellement c'est
très bizarre comme ambition celle de
yannick jadot qu' on ne se déplacerait
sur l'autoroute pour le plaisir pour
voir le paysage peut être non bien sûr
énormément de gens travaillent il suffit
de prendre la voiture et de l'espoir aux
autres pour voir énormément de gens qui
sont en déplacement contre 1 ou alors il
ya peut-être quelques hédoniste qui
prennent l'autoroute pur plaisir mais
c'est six jours là sont curieux et donc
vous avez donc il y avait tant de le
fait de ne pas de rouler plus lentement
ça signifie quoi ça signifie avoir des
plus longs trajets ça signifie mois
pouvoir travailler souvent pour les
indépendants donc c'est pas quelque
chose qui relève du nid d'un sentiment
comme le respect au mépris ni d'une
espèce de liberté concernant de son
donnerait donc c'est une contrainte
économique qui repose notamment sur les
indépendants et quand vous allez sur le
tour je suis pas un spécialiste et
routières et des réglementations genre
je ne conduis pas en tout cas des gros
camions
mais quand vous laisse l'autoroute vous
avez en semaine énormément de véhicules
utilitaires et peut-être
prendre l'autoroute uniquement le
week-end pour partir en week-end
précisément c'est pas les usages
principal de l'autoroute par ailleurs
c'est curieux parce que à la fin j'ai
pris l'autoroute moi j'ai longé quelque
chose qui permet c'était du côté de
montélimar qui permet de lutter
efficacement contre le réchauffement
climatique
ça s'appelle une centrale nucléaire n'a
été très belle le long des autoroutes
françaises et vous avez justement un
point fort de l'économie française de
l'excellence française est quelque chose
de profondément écologique contrairement
à ce qui se passe dans la le temple de
l'écologie européenne et l'allemagne
vous avez précisément phare aux yeux des
français en tout cas vous avez
précisément cette ressource
extraordinaire développer un autre pays
qui est précisément cette énergie
nucléaire qui se modernise vous permet
des gars autrement plus important que
les mesures punitives envisagée on va
rester pour l'instant sur les sur les
autoroutes et sur cette proposition dont
de réduire la vitesse à 110 km/heure
je salue véronique elisabeth et mireille
mireille et sylvie qui nous rejoignent
en ce moment notamment sur les forums du
figaro également citoyen payeur
internautes fidèles et christophe x
alors vous n'avez pas été nombreux à
commenter à propos de citoyens payeurs
la proposition de yannick jadot qui est
de réduire le tarif sur les autoroutes
bertrand perrier est ce que justement ça
vous paraît un bon argument de la part
de yannick jadot question plus large
qu'elle cause
vous aimeriez plaidé dans cette affaire
au conseil d'état ceux qui sont
favorables aux 110 km/heure ceux qui y
sont opposés et en réalité je suis un
peu surpris et d'ul parallèle qui est
fait entre la réduction de 90 à 80 sur
le réseau secondaire et la réduction de
130 à 110 sur les autoroutes les deux ne
paraissent pas du tout répondre à la
même logique et non pas d'ailleurs été
présentés comme ceux devant répondre à
la logique
la logique de la réduction sur le réseau
secondaire était essentiellement une
logique de sécurité routière or là on
sait que le
réseau autoroutier n'est pas très
accidentogène donc la réduction de 130 à
110 sur le réseau autoroutier qu'elle
soit accompagnée ou non est elle si elle
l'est c'est tant mieux
d'une réduction des coûts en tout cas la
réduction ne peut pas être véritablement
motivé par des questions
d'accidentologie puisque le réseau
autoroutier encore une fois est un
réseau très sûre en tout cas beaucoup
plus sûr que le réseau secondaire est
donc la motivation du passage de 130 à
110 sur autoroute ne peut pas se draper
dans l'idée de la sécurité routière mais
uniquement dans des motivations
écologistes et d'ailleurs c'est une
proposition de cette convention
citoyenne qui avait pour fonction de
faire des propositions en matière
d'écologie
et après on nous présente cela comme
permettant une réduction de 20% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre moi je
ne sais pas je ne suis pas spécialiste
mais après tout pourquoi pas si ça c'est
un pacte en réalité comme dans toute
chose c'est une question d' équilibre
entre d'un côté la réduction de 20%
semble-t-il et des gaz à effet de serre
que l'on pourrait attendre d'une
réduction de 130 à 110 de l'habitation
autorisés sur l'autoroute et de l'autre
côté le coup qui a été évaluée également
en termes d'impact du ralentissement et
de l'allongement des trajets qui serait
en année pleine de 550 millions d'euros
donc est ce que on veut que moins 20 %
de gaz à effet de serre soient
privilégiés par rapport à une perte de
550 millions d'euros somme toute la
question se résume à cela
alors justement mathieu broquet votre à
votre avis sur la question et 7
ce dilemme qui est posée par bertrand
perrier jeu j'entends bien effectivement
il s'avère que le crack de voitures
individuelles est l'un des plus gros
émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre en
france
et il fait partie des plus gros dans le
monde donc mais bien sûr que c'est pas
un sujet à prendre en considération
maintenant encore une fois je suis pas
tout à fait sûr que faire une
application d'une mesure et qui pour moi
est du greenwashing
ça va on avait créé de la grogne sociale
j'en suis à peu près certain je suis
plutôt d'accord avec vous la manière
dont s'est présentée c'est pas pour la
même chose c'est pas pour les mêmes
raisons on réduisait à 80 km j'ai dû et
les actions isolées rencontre sur le sur
le fond vous n'êtes pas contre je pense
que c'est pas une mesure qui soit
pertinente en fait je suis pas contre
l'idée en elle-même
effectivement quand on voit les chiffres
et la réduc ça pourrait créer comme il
ya en effet de gaz à effet de serre
voilà ça paraît pas complètement fou
néanmoins c'est une mesure qu'on
appliquerait que en france
or aujourd'hui on le sait si l'on veut
vraiment encore une fois prendre la
mesure du sujet il faut que les choses
elle se passe au niveau européen et je
pense qu'il ya d'autres mesures
autrement plus intéressante
on a longtemps parlé d'un plus tard
bonne d'un prix sur les externalités
négatives il puisse se faire au niveau
européen qui peut se faire avec une
agence indépendante
pourquoi pas moi ça me paraît beaucoup
plus intéressant c'est le mouvement avec
la baisse du prix du pétrole quand
c'était le moment avec la baisse du prix
du pétrole à la sortie du pot vide ça
serait beaucoup plus pertinent ce serait
beaucoup plus harmonisée et ça éviterait
encore une fois de faire une mesure
déclenche de manière un peu épidermique
chez les gens une réaction qui est qui
est mon avis contre productive parce que
il faut bien voir que même si la
finalité est pas mauvaise la manière
dont ces perçu la manière dont ces reçus
va à mon humble entraîné des réactions
très contre-productif pour le sujet et
on a peut-être aujourd'hui en france
autre d'autres sujets bien plus
importants à traiter
alors on va on va y revenir justement je
donne la parole à nos internautes
d'abord christophe qui salue la présence
de richard wehrli dans cette émission
qui nous divise
ble ment les journalistes suisses
romands comprennent mieux les français
que ceux qui nous gouvernent citoyens
payeurs nous dit rouler à 110 sur
l'autoroute et se faire coller par les
poids lourds non merci
110 km heure sur une autoroute du dic
liste christophe sera bien plus
impopulaire que le 80 km heure sur les
nationales et et vous débattez ensemble
vous n'êtes pas toujours d'accord à dld
vous nous dites je roulerai à 110
km/heure sur les autoroutes et je ne
serai pas jamais pris par les radars et
je ne donnerai pas d'argent aux comptes
publics ça c'est un argument alors il
débat également sur la page facebook du
figaro véronique nous dit dans les
alpes-maritimes ça fait quelques années
que déjà ses 110 km/heure sur autoroute
et c'est vrai que c'est 110 km/heure
également sur certaines portions
d'autoroute également autour de paris
elisabeth sur facebook dit non moi je
préfère l 130 kilomètres/heure alors
pourquoi elisabeth préférez-vous 130
kilomètres heure justement c'est la
question notamment pour les
et qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux
qui vous disent que ce serait moins
polluants de rouler moins vite et
mireille nous dit je ne prendrai plus
l'autoroute pour payer aussi cher pour
rouler à 110 km/heure qu'ils connaissent
et sylvie nous dit qu'il commette qu'ils
commencent par mettre les camions sur
les rails et ils verront que la qualité
de l'air s'en trouvera améliorée dans ce
cas il faut que les autoroutes baisse de
prix nous dit cathy sur facebook et
effectivement c'est ce que propose
notamment
ganic jadot il ya une autre proposition
qui a été faite c'est une question qu'on
a posés sur la base d'internautes du
figaro hier au secrétaire d'état aux
transports jean baptiste djebbari et qui
propose de soumettre cet ensemble de
mesures à référendum qu'est ce que vous
en pensez jérôme sainte marie
le problème du référendum est toute
simple d'une part ça ça mobilise se doit
un peu d'argent d'autre part c'est en
soi tout et poésie toujours populaire un
référendum à quel que soit le sujet les
gens sont toujours prêts à les décider
par eux mêmes mais c'est quand même
compliqué parce que cela ouvre un peu la
boîte de pandore s'émeut commencé par
faire des référendums sur des sujets qui
préoccupent relativement peu les gens
vous avez du mal à expliquer pourquoi
vous ne pouvez pas en faire pour des
sujets qui le préoccupent réellement les
gens donc ça vous créez un problème
démocratique en quelque sorte avec des
référendums de confort en quelque sorte
pour le pouvoir qui est un des mots qui
suscitent une demande démocratique qui
n'aboutit pas je vous rappelle que il ya
eu quand même une pétition qui n'a pas
abouti sur la privatisation d'aéroports
de paris
il ya un sujet quand même qui n'est pas
mince en termes de souveraineté en terme
d'image de légitimité même des mesures
économiques du gouvernement
hé hé bien c'est le référendum n'aura
pas lieu
cette réforme n'a pas lieu il ya
pourtant eu des millionnaires le score
nécessaire n'a pas été atteint pour ça
repasse devant le parlement et
qu'ensuite et ceux des planches
éventuellement référendum mais ça n'a
pas eu lieu
alors après l'aéroport de paris est donc
le nom référendum soyons pas de paris
après le avant le nom référendum sur des
sujets que dans la
noah des sondages pour demander
souhaitez-vous qu'en face des référendum
sur tel ou tel sujet qui intéresse mans
l intéresse vraiment les français on va
leur faire un référendum sur un sujet
qui est pour eux relativement secondaire
ça me paraîtrait c'est possible c'est
possible à faire mais ça me paraîtrait
une maladresse sans compter que face à
pouvoir emprunt populaire prend toujours
un risque évidemment en faisant un
référendum sur n'importe quel sujet
alors je salue les internautes du figaro
chahut également les enfants qu'on
entend également dans cette émission ça
donne un peu de fraîcheur et ça me sort
un peu de la froideur des déchets alors
on retrouve deux minutes on donne la
parole aux internautes ou là il ya eu du
grabuge au passage je salue babineau je
salue risque ricercar également qu'ils
nous rejoignent
christophe nous dit c'est effectivement
du greenwashing de la com comme toujours
en suisse nous dire i sort car ces 120
kilomètres heure mais les distances ne
sont pas les mêmes et citoyens payeurs
que le bien nommé nous dit tout
conducteur ne se faisant pas racketter
dans l'année par un au moins un radar
sera déclarée mauvais contribuables
d'ailleurs je vous donne rendez-vous à
propos demain à partir de 11h pierre
pilet est par skype en direct avec
l'avocat rémy josseaume justement la
bête noire des radars et vous pourrez
lui poser toutes vos questions notamment
sur 7 sur ce thème je rappelle la
question composé sur twitter vous avez
été nombreux pas autant ne pas aussi
nombreux que sur le site du figaro
étaient nombreux sur twitter à répondre
à cette question c'était pas un sondage
c'était juste une question faut-il
limiter et limiter la vitesse à 110 êtes
vous prêt à rouler à 110 kilomètres sur
l'autoroute question que vous posez sur
twitter et vous êtes 78% à répondre non
non vous n'êtes plus modérée dans votre
réponse que vous ne mettiez sur le site
du figaro